Năm Gờ và NFC, Phô Các Semi-Dia, Rồi Mới, Nguang Kào Thành Mày, vừa qua tại sự kiện
The New Era of Elevator Media của Phô Các Semi-Dia Việt Nam, công bố bước tính mới
trong lần cấp hả tân truyền thông thẳng máy tất thập công nghệ Năm Gờ và NFC,
quy tổ hơn hai trong đại biểu là cửa quan băng ăn, ect. Nổi tiếng như WPP,
At Micro, Cốc Cốc, Nhi Group, E-Nox, Thật Đó, Phô Các Semi-Dia Việt Nam đã cho thấy
thành dình tiếp cận mới, từ chảm, mở chàng, ở lại, hành động, tạo câu nối liên mặt giữa quan cám
ngoài để thật và đần tảng số của thương hiểu.
Các mữ tại sự kiện ông Xiang Song, tổng giám nó công ty Phô Các Semi-Dia Việt Nam,
cùng bà sầm Minh Hành, giám nóc mặt cái đing Phô Các Semi-Dia Việt Nam những mạnh rằng
Chúng tôi không thay đổi vài cho một chiếc thông thẳng máy.
Chúng tôi thay đổi, kể điều sĩ ra, soch mạnh khách chủy.
Còn đó, mạnh đến cấp nhìn thực tính về phai trò ngày càng mở trong của truyền thông thẳng máy trong chính lực truyền thông thình đại.